willkommen zur nächsten sitzung des
seminares philosophische zu uns theorien
heute wollen wir uns an erneut mit der
frage befassen was eine emotion ist in
der letzten sitzung wo ich da oben
rechts einen link damit youtube hinein
mache hatten wir schon so ein paar
fragen diskutiert ist vorläufig gewesen
auch in der heutigen sitzung wird es nur
vorläufig sein können
sie werden sehen dass wir die emotionen
nicht auf anhieb vielleicht auch
überhaupt nicht vollständig definieren
können mit definition meine ich jetzt
die wörtlichen sinn abgrenzen also
wirklich eine abgrenzung vornehmen von
verwandten phänomenen die eben nicht
emotionen sind darum sollte der heutigen
sitzung gehen
was ist deine emotionen das ist die
spannende frage ich hatte in den letzten
sitzungen versucht gemacht die zu
bestimmen also ich hatte gesagt
emotionen sind komplexe subjektiv
expressive zustände das ist jetzt
natürlich auch wieder ein ja ein wort
konglomerat 1 1 riesen willst von
begriffen das macht die sache ist auch
noch nicht klar
musste auch noch genauer eingehen
emotionen drücken die gesamte
subjektivität aus also emotionen werden
immer von subjekten gehabt das ist ja
auch interessantes thema emotionen
scheinen nur von lebewesen gehabt haben
zu können und zwar von bestimmten
lebewesen nämlich lebewesen die
besonders hoch entwickelt sind also von
menschlichen tieren wie wir es sind mit
sicherheit auch von mensch laufen
eventuell von delfinen
es sind lebewesen aber es müssen
besondere geben ist sein und computer
und roboter und so weiter künstliche
intelligenz als gerade ein riesen thema
ist scheint nicht der lage sein
emotionen authentisch zu fühlen
auch wenn künstliche intelligenz oder
roboter emotionen simulieren können das
ist sicherlich möglich aber subjektiv
sie zu haben einen zustand
emotionalität dass sein das scheint
nicht möglich zu sein darüber können wir
aber auch noch in einer der nächsten
sitzung diskutieren ist ganz spannendes
thema emotionen drücken die gesamte
subjektivität aus und motivieren dadurch
besonders gut zur freien handlung ich
habe jetzt hier bewusst frei nochmal
eingefügt und zwar deswegen weil
emotionen ganz eng mit effekten verwandt
sind die man es auch motivieren zur
handlung aber häufig nicht zu feiner
dumm sondern zu handlungen im affekt wie
man zur schweiz und zu denen man häufig
wenn sie es dann unmoralischen
handlungen sind oder ist jetzt das
widrige handlung sind eben nicht im
vollen umfang zurechenbar verurteilt
wird weil man von ihnen gewissermaßen
über und dann wurde der politik wurde
also deswegen betone ich jetzt hier
emotionen haben doch etwas mit freiheit
zu tun
alles ist effekte haben die eher etwas
mit unfreiheit zu haben scheinen darüber
können wir genauer diskutieren emotionen
sind ferner stabil und erlauben damit
reflexion und rationalität diesen stabil
sie vergeben nicht einfach sie fliegen
nicht einfach so wie sie gekommen sind
wie es häufig perfekten der fall ist und
das erlaubt es deswegen sie zu formen
sie zu kultivieren sie zu reflektieren
also zu ihnen stellung zu nehmen bevor
sie wieder verflogen sind wenn jemand
darauf reflektieren kann kann man sie
eben auch als eine gewisse form von
rationalität bezeichnen
das ist zumindest die rationalität
zugänglich während emotionen während
effekte ihr die tendenz haben sich der
betrachtung der reflektierten
betrachtung zu entziehen weil sie eben
so impulsiv und so kurzlebig bin auch
sehr energetisch gehalten sind
ja das ist so meine vorläufigen kennzahl
gewesen jetzt fragen wir uns wie können
wir emotionen definieren und zwar im
wörtlichen sinne definieren inszeniertes
abgrenzen definition heißt die
abgrenzung eine bestimmung ist gerade
dann bei emotionen eben sinnvoll
von verwandten phänomenen wie effekten
wie gefühlen und kann also das ist unser
ziel heuer der heutigen sitzung noch
einmal wir haben letztens jetzt schon
gemacht als wir wollen emotionen und
gefühle effekt und stimmung abgrenzen
das soll jetzt heute mein zentrum stehen
ein gefühl würde ich jetzt mal bestimmen
wir können darüber noch genauer
definieren als ihr äußerlicher eindruck
nicht als ein innerlicher ausdruck also
gefühle sind nicht so sehr mit unserem
unten mit unserer subjektivität
verbunden wie es emotionen sind nur ein
beispiel
wir bestehen nicht aus hunger hunger ist
etwas in uns dass wir vernehmen
aber es ist doch letztendlich äußerlich
vergleich zur liebe war als eine emotion
effekt ist ein momentaner ausdruck
unserer gesamten unverstellten
subjektivität aber eben ein momentan
sehr energetischer impulsiver ausdruck
und deswegen auch häufig eine
motivationsquelle ja nicht beherrschte
handlungen könnt ihr sagen also wir sind
da nicht ganz herr unserer selbst in den
affen eine stimmung hingegen ist
durchaus eine wusste auszug also eine
stimmung hat eine ausdehnung eine
stimmung hat eine konstanz die vergeht
nicht einfach so schnell oder zu
verfliegen nicht so schnell bekommt
nicht so schnell wie wow effekten
aber sie scheint mir aber darüber kann
man noch diskutieren nicht unsere
gesamte subjektivität auszumachen wie es
im falle von evolution ist so das ist
jetzt mal eine vorläufige bestimmung und
jetzt würde ich nochmal kurz meine
klassifizierungs tabelle bringen auch
darüber kann man diskutieren also ich
habe hier leben unterschieden integral
zur pi tiefe direkt partiell solidität
robuste ausdehnung extension bhutan und
hier sehen wir dass emotionen wie zb die
liebe die ich jetzt im folgenden immer
als paradigmatisch emotion wählen werde
dass die liebe besonders ausgezeichnet
ist weil sie eben doch unsere gesamte
subjektivität betrifft und auch bewusst
ist also nicht einfach verfliegen mann
verliebt sich nicht
einfach so vielleicht schon aber die
liebe in man sich dann verliebt geht
nicht so schnell wieder weg
etwas anderes ist es zum glück wie zum
beispiel mit wut wenn man wütend ist
dann verfliegt diese erregung durchaus
schneller
im gegensatz zum hals darauf wurde ich
sehr zu recht mit letzten sitzung
hingewiesen der hass scheint kein affekt
zu sein wie die wut sondern der hass
scheint eine emotion zu sein weil er
längerfristig sich gestritten kann im
sinne von hass verbrechen wir haben
jetzt in der aktuellen debatte den hass
wieder auf dem programm hate speech und
sofort also die hass kann so eine
einstellung werden was die wurde in
meinen augen nicht kann
das ist jetzt so ein vorschlag der
platzierung ich verweise hier viel
lowcost wo sie die tabelle finden und
auch in der zusammenfassung die ihn
herum geschickt habe
und jetzt sehen wird das
wir hier die integrale subjektivität
haben also die gesamte subjektivität
wenn emotionen eine rolle spielen wir
eine besonders starke emotionale kraft
haben
dazu kommt noch die ihre robustheit sich
verfliegt nicht einfach so schnell wie
jetzt zb bei perfekten wie die wut der
fall ist dh die bleibt dadurch haben wir
auch noch der reflexion reflex dimension
und in dieser schnittmenge von
multinationale graf unsere flexibilität
darlehen eben die emotionen und das
macht sie in meinen augen wieder
verstummt besonders so jetzt wollen wir
mal hier ist eine kleine auflistung
geben und darüber wollen wir dann auch
im folgenden der heutigen sitzung
diskutieren
das möchte ich zur debatte gerne auch
bei youtube unten die kommentare
reinschreiben dann ob sie das genauso
sehen ob es antritt
qualifizierungsmöglichkeiten gibt also
liebe ist für mich wirklich die
paradigmatische emotion zu vergleichen
zu verbringen sind jetzt von vielleicht
gefühlen und effekten der sexuellen lust
das muss man doch deutlich davon
abgrenzen auch uns hat deswegen weil es
eben diese robustheit hat diese konstanz
mitleid scheint mir auch eine emotion zu
sein aber etwas mehr von einem effekt zu
haben
denken sie mal nach sie sehen ein gerade
mit leidens nette person und die fühlen
sich geradezu hingerissen
um ihr zu helfen da könnte man durchaus
davon sprechen dass es eine art von
effektivität ist wie bekommen sie ja und
es geht dann vielleicht auch schnell
wieder kern wollen wir jetzt mal zur
debatte stellen mittelhessen emotion ist
diese szene wie ich jetzt evolution
verstehe dann achtung das achtungsgebot
eine sehr niedrigschwellige
emotionalität an einerseits aber dann
auch eine gewisse form von rationalität
ist eine einstellung angehen
achtungsvoll einstellung die gilt einer
anderen person oder wer team für längere
zeit
das wurde das letzte mal zu recht betont
hast kann sich erstrecken ist kein
impulsives perfekt phänomen wie jetzt
zum beispiel die gut das ist eine
einstellung passt kann kultiviert werden
hate speech hassverbrechen und so weiter
zu fahren
im hass können wir eine lesekultur sogar
zurück eine kultur des hasses das ist
durchaus möglich so schlimm sie auch
sein mag erscheint mir auch
längerfristig zu sein also nicht zu
einer fit zu sein man mag sich zwar
plötzlich schämen aber charme hat doch
eine extension wohin der scham drückt
sich wie ich finde auch die ganze
subjektivität aus beziehungsweise die
ganze subjektivität ist betroffen
wir sind im schamgefühl in der scham
emotion betroffen
ja vielleicht noch zuletzt zuletzt auch
den weit ist vielleicht wieder hast eine
sehr negative emotion aber auch der neid
kann über längere zeit sich strecken in
erstrecken auch der neid kann zu einer
form von kultur wählen eine kultur des
neides man spricht von einer
neidgesellschaft im flight jetzt in
zeiten von corona also neid es
allgegenwärtig und weiter durchaus auch
etwas mit rationalität zu tun weil wir
im leid immer auch eine überlegung
durchführen und einen vergleich
anstellen und einer anderen person ein
anderen gesellschaft und an die
bevölkerung die angeblich vorzug wird
und man selbst ungerecht behandelt wird
daraus dass diese reflexion dass diese
überlegung resultiert eben auch ein
emotionaler ausdruck
im gegensatz jetzt aber zu einer station
hat der neid als emotionen die tendenz
sich zu vermehren
also in der letzten sitzung kamen die
frage auftauchte berechtigter einwand
müssen nicht emotional emotionen immer
eine körperliche seite haben eine
ausdruck seite emotion sagt ja auch
heraus bewegung wird wörtlich ich glaube
ihm leid ist es ja so eine heraus
bewegung die wieder in sich hinein
verläuft also so eine art rückwirkende
emotion der neid bleibt in einen selbst
im mai wird man vermissen wird man
verkrampft also in light wird gerade
nichts nach außen gelassen
dann würde man ja das ist das scheint
mir etwas gesagt besonders spannende
emotion zu sein
nein
so jetzt gehen wir mal weiter zum
gefühlen wir haben hier hunger das ist
für mich als paradigmatisch gefühl hoher
betrifft nicht unsere gesamte
subjektivität gute mögen vielleicht
manchmal extremen homann empfinden aber
auch dann bleibt uns der hohe doch
äußerlich dieses etwas in uns was wir
spüren was aber dürfen uns eigentlich an
unterschieden ist in dem wir auch nicht
so ganz aufgehen wie es jetzt im teile
der liebe der fall ist
durst genauso schmerz vielleicht auch
ein paar dogmatisches gefühl und schmerz
kann sich natürlich länger gestritten
aber er geht auch im moment eher auf
lust auch ein gefühltes sein
ekel ist jetzt die spannende frage ist
ein gefühl oder ist nicht mittel ihr ein
affekt oder ist eklat mendiger eine
emotion wie jetzt beiseite den wir auch
noch im seminar behandelt werden das
hängt natürlich ganz davon ab was wir
jetzt munter einen igel verstehen wie
wir den ekel genau verstehen
jetzt komme ich zu den effekten wir
haben die wut da werden hingerissen dann
die zum auch hingerissen und überwältigt
davon ganz impulsiv soll es uns das
vorstellen aber eben nur kurz von kurzer
dauer
ekel wenn sie eine reaktion haben ich
habe ein beispiel gebracht ein stück
fleisch wasser maden durchsetzte sind
sehr schlecht trifft stinkt und das
sehen dann weichen sie zurück instinktiv
und der ig metall wieder abklingen wenn
sie sich woanders hin
vielleicht wird er noch nach das kann
durchaus sein wenn er zu einer
dauerhaften einstellung wird dann könnte
man tatsächlich von einer emotion
sprechen wie es halt tun wenn er eben
nicht nur einem stück fleisch das
verfault ist gilt vielleicht der welt
als solcher weil die welt begegnet uns
ständig ein stück fleisch leben nicht je
nachdem was das objekt auch dieses
subjektiven zustand ist aber dass wir
auch noch genauer sprechen müssen wir
haben bisher nur die zyklik zeitdiebe
trakt der emotion
es soll noch immer die objekt zu
betrachten also wem oder was gilt diese
emotionen lust je nachdem wie wir lust
verstehen aber so ein triebhafte lustig
finden kann man durchaus als effekt
verstehen versucht denke ich auch wenn
man all versucht recht impulsiv steht
als ein als eine unmoralische handlung
der aus eifersucht geschieht kann man
genauso analogen sylvie wut verstehen
und die verzweiflung wäre dann ein
effekt wenn sie inszeniertes der wut zu
verstehen als person zu bekommen wir
können aber natürlich verzweifelt auch
anders verstehen dass verzweiflung wie
jetzt auch im fall des ekels ein
permanenter zustand unseres selbst welt
verhältnisses wird wie es zum beispiel
gesagt
in diesem fall können wir durchaus auch
die verzweiflung als eine emotion fassen
so jetzt komme ich zum schluss noch den
spielern zu sprechen also stimmung das
sind tönungen das sind ja einfärbungen
unseres gemütszustand ist also freude
wäre so etwas heute die stimmung trauer
im gegensatz dazu ekstase wäre
vielleicht auch eine stimmung im
gegensatz zum effekt dauert diese
stimmung länger aber sie erfüllt uns
nicht diese subjektivität wie jetzt zum
beispiel hier tun
die erlaubt auch keine große
flexibilität sondern ist in der stimmung
versunken und denkt gerade nicht vier
sondern lässt sich einfach gehen
da fehlt ein moment der aktivität wie es
bei der liebe zum beispiel der fall auch
eine motivation die kraft fehlt die
melancholie
das ist auch seine träge einstellung
überhaupt bestimmung etwas träge und
nichts aktives depressionen
und so weiter das scheint mir besonders
geeignete kandidaten verstimmen ja damit
haben wir jetzt mal eine abgrenzung
vorgenommen negative definition also wir
haben jetzt gesagt was im emotion nicht
ist wie sich emotionen geben abgrenzt im
negativen zehner und wir müssen jetzt
immer mehr dahin kommen eine positive
definition eine positive stimmung die
emotionen vorzunehmen der heutigen
sitzung haben jetzt fragen und so
vorgenommen nämlich folgende worin
besteht der gefühls aspekt von emotion
worin besteht der motivation suspect von
emotionen und worin besteht der urteils
aspekt von emotionen ich beziehe mich
hier auf diesen artikel der stanford
enzyklopädie of philosophy den ich auch
unten im youtube-video dann reinmache
über emotionen auf dem wir heute auch
noch eingehen werden der eben diese drei
aspekte hier besonders und wie ich auf
die mütze recht betonen
ja das ist diese artikel den sie
kostenlos finden die mich nun auch
zugeschickt habe und der stunde bis zum
jahr 2018 nicht mal ein paar zitate noch
wo lesen hier sagen wir auch schon
zurecht momente life is more important
uhr die quality and me now for existence
denn die motion die armut maclife
wölfling
sometimes 12 ending sei dass nutzer
price that most of the crate klasse
kommt über cedric packheiser bis auf die
motion ist also emotionen sind deswegen
eher philosophisch so zentral weil sie
unsere existenz unser mentales leben
ich möchte hinzufügen in seiner ganzen
ausdehnung und nicht nur mit einer
teilweisen existenz betreffen also man
könnte sagen emotionen betreffen unsere
existenz insgesamt sind deswegen
existenziell existenziell bedroht sein
wir werden deswegen auch sehen dass
besonders die existenz philosophen also
kirche gott heiliger und auch dass die
den emotionen auch wenn sie manchmal
anders nennen als mann nennen sie die
auch stimmungen wie zum beispiel
heiliger
ich glaube es sind aber emotionen
eigentlich eine ganz besondere bedeutung
zumessen
also existenzieller natur und deswegen
haben auf alle großen philosophinnen und
philosophen dazu etwas geschrieben
weiter sagt dieser artikel ist der preis
in that much of the twentieth century
scientist fest endet ohne klick die
motion pictures of behavioral energy
trina menschen states airport begrüßte
bereit hier phänomenale dithmarschen ist
caritas die vier reifen also gibt es
zwei gründe warum die emotionen obwohl
dies so deutschland sind philosophisch
und auch psychologisch an im zwanzigsten
jahrhundert zu wenig beachtung gefunden
haben ein kommt ist dieser die juris
muss behält juris muss sagt wir können
mentale phänomene immer nur anhand des
verhaltens stimmen also anhand der
äußerlichkeit also die sich etwas
äußerliches
wie es objektivierbar ist könnte man
auch sagen also subjektivität wird auf
objektivität reduzierte perdue riss muss
oder man schließt vom objektiven
verhalten zurück auf innere zustände
das hat natürlich einen sehr
naturwissenschaft diesem jahr ein
quantifizierbare ideal was dahinter
steht aber man verpasst leben so diese
eigentliche ja phänomenale qualität dem
und zu wenn man nur biologistisch
vorgeht ist ein sehr nationalistisch
technische zugang zu diesem thema das
ist der eine grund der andere grund ist
den wir jetzt auch schon angesprochen
hatten das eben
der begriff emotion oder das wort
emotionen so viele verwandte phänomene
auf den plan ruft dass man es fast nicht
hinbekommt emotionen davon definieren
abzugrenzen und zwar eindeutig zu
bestimmen
das ist dieses hier sind also der
begriff der emotion entzieht sich
gewissermaßen unsere ordner den verstand
und systematisieren denn vernunft und
dass wir in diesem seminar machen wollen
ist ebenso gutes kate doch die emotionen
zu begreifen abzugrenzen in negativer
hinsicht in abgrenzenden phänomen und
kategorien und in positiver hinsicht
im sinne einer phänomenologischen
gräflichen bestimmen ja weiter sagt
jetzt die artikel in riesen tk zwar in
motion 20ern bekannte folglich und
michael das interesse für ein effektives
1 objektiv bis ein christ account für
dies development for classical primarily
und wird die skripte question of modern
art question of wales am national
allerdings in jüngster zeit sagen jetzt
jedenfalls diese autoren habe das thema
emotionen größere bedeutung erfahren
mich nur in der philosophie sondern auch
in der jemand auch immer nennt in der
psychologie möchte sie zwangen
und jetzt wollen diese autorin zwei
fragen bezüglich demo zu unterscheiden
einmal die deskriptive frage was
emotionen sind mit der wir uns heute
dieser sitzung befassen und die native
frage ob emotionen rational sind ich
hatte mich etwas gewundert ich weiß
nicht ich im gegen als ich jetzt lass
normative frage betrifft die frage ob
emotion hat also warum ist das nirgendwo
zu machen es dass eine normative fragen
hast du eigentlich die deskriptive frage
nicht wenn man emotionen bestimmt dann
kann man sie als rational und als nicht
rational spielen das ist auch das
kreative schreiben
klar kann man so sehen allerdings ist
ist ja natürlich rationalität häufig
positiv kommentiert als arzt hat das was
gutes als wünschenswertes und weil es
ein wert verkörpert kann man das
durchhalten informative also wert hafte
wertende fragestellung bestehen ob
emotional rational sind ist also eine
normative frage und können natürlich
auch noch die normative frage so
verstehen engeren sinn sind emotionen
wünschen zu gehen oder nicht aber hier
ist jetzt schluss zugrunde was rational
ist ist wünschenswert wenn die emotionen
rational sind dann sind sie
wünschenswert
das wäre so die normative einstellungs
emotionen weiter geht es im text freunde
maßen emotion selfstorage libyen
conceptual heißt in love remains the
experience ist des überlegens eines
motivation schafft dies research
traditions cage is something to end
signifikant im ausschuss für den manager
posten im juni account exempel
zeitproblem case wie gesagt hier kommen
jetzt die drei dimensionen zur sprache
die in diesem artikel sehr treffend
genannt werden nämlich emotionen als
erfahrungen man könnte auch sagen als
gefühle
sie gefühlt seit als evaluation als
bewertungen und als motivationsquelle
das habe ich als ja auch schon in meiner
klassifikation berücksichtigt das finde
ich sehr spannend
ich glaube dass das bedeutende
emotionalen besteht diese drei
dimensionen ineinander zu vereinigen und
diese drei dimensionen der person die
zeigen sich die jetzt die autoren
argumentieren auch in verschiedenen
traditionen der forschung und man muss
aber auch kritisch dazu sagen dass keine
der tradition ja eine vollständige
einheitliche konsistente bestimmung
generation bringt wein immer wieder
gegenbeispiele entwickelt werden können
die dann doch diese systematisierung
zerstört das ist auch in der philosophie
kann ich mir ganz generell sagen immer
so eine tendenz man will ein phänomen
oder anwendung im bereich voll schmidt
definieren und dann kommen wieder
gegenbeispiele auf und dann müssen
unsere ganze systemen umwerfen oder
modifizieren
hier sieht es wieder ganz anders aus das
wollen wir versuchen schaffen wir es in
diesem sinn eine vollständige
konsistente eindeutige definition der
emotion
hinzu kommt ohne gegenbeispiele die
diese klassifizierung wieder in frage
stellt es gibt es noch ein zitat dass
ich ihn nicht vor teilen möchte die
autoren zu haben weiter
colin farrell die menschen des abkommens
ist die panik disposition
primitiv kognitive processing vier
seiten leonie anna des entwurfs festigen
damit processing idp lösungen jazz mit
zusammen 45 prozent
ein anders legden mit red könnte auch
noch hier sagen zum beispiel leitwolfs
from ovations di resta das duhner
wattrennen crosbys vielen als
exclusively jungen schaden voll das ist
eines der lieblingswörter dass in den
angelsächsischen sprachen eingegangen
ist wie kindergarten und waldsterben und
angst also schadenfreude wird jetzt hier
auch als eine evolution bezeichnet ich
finde das ganz zutreffend
wobei man hier jetzt noch ein bisschen
kritisch werden könnte
schadenfreude ist er jetzt ein
dauerhafter zustand ein starteinsatz
zustand oder nicht ob ihr etwas momentan
ist ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher kann
man nachher diskutieren wenn
schadenfreude jetzt also eine
unmittelbare reaktion auf ein
missgeschick verstanden eine person
rutscht auf einer bananenschale aus und
man dann schaden so reagiert und lacht
zum beispiel dann scheint mir das fast
schon wie ein effekt zu sein nicht eine
evolution noch immer darüber kann man
weiterdiskutieren zum schluss noch
dieses zitat wenn ihr auf dass sings mit
commotions dfb in die ob sie denn alles
ist live search of fashion statement des
treffens movement passion ab mitte des
wegs vom namen complete history das
progressive leland über die batman
bereitstellen
die menschen hier wird jetzt wieder sehr
treffend lieben weitere phänomene
genannt passionen an das haben wir jetzt
nicht an ganz noch wieder aufgenommen
man sagt ja auch einen deutschen nicht
so häufig passion sentiment
gefühl frage abgrenzung cent wäre das
gefühl was ist der unterschied faction
effekt des treffens mit patience also
das hängt jetzt noch weitere
klassifizierungen ich glaube aber dass
die vier oder drei abgrenzenden gefühl
effekt und stimmen an
doch fast schon hinreichend sind das
werde ich auch eine frage gibt es nach
einem weiteren phänomen bereich den wir
als abgrenzung noch hinzuziehen müssen
über um die emotionen eindeutig zu
definieren
ja das war es jetzt in der
zusammenfassung die ich jetzt gleich auf
youtube stellen und wir gehen jetzt
gleich weiter in die diskussion